my name is Lee Commerce and I am
Canada's World Cup Super Fan
I've been to the last four World Cups
Canada has qualified for the first time
in 36 years I've been waiting my whole
life for this
started in World Cup 1994 when it came
to the United States it was an instant
hook I was addicted from the beginning
and in 2010 when a South African fan set
the Guinness World Record of 31 matches
I wanted that title
Guinness has a list of items that I need
to accomplish one of them is I need to
be in my seat before the match starts
and I must stay in my seat until the
match ends so no bathroom breaks I also
have to have two witnesses at each match
that I actually was there I have to
provide match tickets greatest souvenirs
is our is our match coffee ticket it
starts really early we try to get as
much sleep as possible because it is it
is an exhausting Adventure but I
absolutely love it
the biggest challenge is getting from
one Stadium to the next stadium with
forty thousand sixty thousand fans all
trying to maneuver the same way
you need to maximize every single day
you're here so to start the record I
have 16 days in a row of two matches a
day and it's very important I've been
cutting it close I was only four minutes
out from USA whale
I'm a little run down
I know that I'm going to want to make
this as memorable as possible so you
just gotta battle through those tired
moments
guitar will go down in history as having
the closest proximity of stadiums where
you can go to two stadiums a day and
that'll be the Legacy they leave
as a Canadian fan you can feel alone at
times but what this world cup I
discovered that there are a lot of
Canadian fans
[Applause]
[Music]
a lot of friends from my home City even
my mother has traveled to this one
foreign
what football does and what the World
Cup can accomplish is it unites the
world everyone shares the joy everyone
is happy here you feel it you wave you
smile there's the friendly banter but
it's it's healthy and everyone's here
for the same reason